can I just say what a pleasure it is to
be working with you again I don't think
we need the silencer and I to move you
to live in them to London I've hunted in
set the delivery permit to me you came
all the way from London for us
hands up drop the bag okay kick over to
me right now kick over me right now are
you serious okay from the top the
American stole about it that will get it
to that camera
[Music]
what's that time does it match my blue
eyes steal it back collect the reward
five to six million
[Music]
stay where you are game over man it's
over
let's go let's go let's go let's go what
happens to the normal people's like me
you're going for the whole Billy Ray
Cyrus thing that shuts off business in
the front party in the back where you
wearing are you what do you ron jeremy
this is what this is what I wear what
I'm thinking stop [ __ ] can't go in there
guns ablaze it says very small very
small
good morning it's over good morning
I might get me pretty good
you